fox news alert the first whistleblower
of the biden administration has just
come forward tonight and said joe
biden's attorney general lied to
congress the fbi absolutely used its
counterterrorism division to investigate
parents at school board meetings
according to leaked emails the fbi
created a threat tag to track school
board incidents and track parents
themselves
write in quote we ask that your offices
apply the threat tag to investigations
of threats specifically directed at
school board administrators board
members teachers and staff
this memo also undercuts garland's sworn
testimony before congress watch
the justice department
supports and defends the first amendment
right of parents to complain as
vociferously as they wish about the
education of their
children about the curriculum taught in
the schools
that is not what the memorandum is about
at all i can't imagine any circumstance
in which the patriot act would be used
in the circumstances
of parents complaining about their
children nor can i imagine a
circumstance where they would be labeled
as domestic terrorism
so garland's sworn testimony was a lie
lying to congress is usually a crime
what exactly did the fbi do to innocent
parents why did they treat them like
domestic terrorists and why did the
attorney general lie and cover up the
program when he testified under oath to
congress
here for more reaction is missouri
senator josh hawley senator
this doesn't look good i have this
little leaked memorandum right here this
looks like they were going after parents
hardcore this is the criminal division
and the counterterrorism division of the
fbi
what this shows us is that in fact
parents are getting the domestic
terrorist treatment garland said oh no
we would never treat them like domestic
terrorists course that's what those
left-wing groups wanted garland said no
we're not going to do that and now we
know that the counterterrorism division
has been tracking parents and not only
that if you read that leaked email what
you see is is that they are drawing up
lists of crimes they're saying is there
any crime that we could go after these
parents for is there anything that we
could prosecute them for federal crimes
we're talking about they're definitely
trying to target parents it does
contradict garland's sworn testimony and
now he's going to have to answer as to
what the difference is and according to
this memo i have right here the date
says there should have been already a
meeting between fbi officials u.s
attorneys
local state authorities so i mean this
thing's already out of the gate on a
number of levels what can you do as a
senator if the ag lies to your face what
can you guys do about that
well at the very least we're going to
need to put him back under oath and
bring up for the committee and say what
in the world's going on i mean this is a
guy who even as he was before us in the
senate it came out that his justice
department had drawn up a list of 13
federal crimes that parents could
possibly be charged for that
contradicted what he was telling us in
real time he was sitting there saying oh
we wouldn't charge parents and then we
we obtained a memo from a justice
department prosecutor that said here are
13
possible crimes the attorney general has
a problem with the truth he needs to
come back and answer under oath what is
going on here why is the patriot act
being used against parents yeah he sure
does and uh
lying to congress i i heard people used
to get in trouble for that i guess some
people still are getting in trouble for
that
i don't know if he's gonna get in
trouble he probably won't because he's a
democrat so we'll see how that all
shakes out this just looks really bad
considering what the fbi did with the
trump campaign and now with parents i
think it's just a renegade agency that
needs to be held accountable and from
what i remember whistleblowers were
heroes
in the media i'd like to see how this
whistleblower gets treated we're going
to find out very soon we're going to now
talk to you about something i think is
near and dear to your heart this crt
garbage that you're pushing back on some
wacko some 1619 lady on the view today
said this listen
for every story of a teacher who may or
may not be doing a white privilege
exercise you have a story of a teacher
who's doing a mock slave auction in
their classroom so we're only hearing
that one is a problem these are good
faith efforts to really
deal with the structural inequality to
explain to students how does a black man
get killed on national television by a
police officer to explain to children
how do we have an insurrection on our
capitol
so senator crt is just a counterweight
to these slave auctions that are
apparently happening throughout public
schools in this country and then she
brought up you specifically by name your
reaction
well what my reaction is is the folks
who are the advocates of crt live in an
alternative universe and they live in an
alternative america they want to teach
our kids and they're trying to do it
that america is systemically evil
systemically racist and oppressive and
the worst part of it is they say that if
you as a parent and i'm a parent of
three kids if you as a parent object to
that you're a racist you're a bigot
you're a domestic terrorist like we've
just seen it's crazy and that's why i've
introduced legislation to protect
parents rights to make sure that parents
have the right to go to school board
meetings have the right to know what
their kids are being taught have the
right to control their children's
education because yeah parents are the
most important part of a kid's education
we should protect that all right senator
hawley will be looking for that
legislation and follow up we appreciate
you coming on primetime